antes de começar o vídeo gostaria de
informar que voz do ano está um pouco
baixa porque o skype
eu mesmo lento nem olha que eu não
consigo o cheiro daqui a uma hora
não faltou senso um jovem muito futuro
pela falta de frutos meu começa a baixar
mil ea brisa que eu queria ir a um chefe
ou eu porque faltou me amigo sou eu
tenho andando eu vou saber se meu tipo
lá eu tenho que manter o fluxo não vai
dar certo a gente chateado e hotel
morosoni outubro 26 vídeos foi assim ela
vai ficar eu vou chegar lá acima
primeiro é tão já tocou em cima amigo
é que o preço da equipe é alto e não é
eu eu já me olha com quatro frentes tira
tira a vida era eu vou ganhar amanhã não
olha vê estou a correr stones olimpíadas
funciona lá o primeiro que tudo estava a
jogar vou tentar acertar citou ganhamos
quase ok ela olha lá mas como vai se
sair melhor que o tempo vai dizer eu vi
uma luz tipo malhação olha que machado
depois banheiros machado está aqui uma
chave micha machado da área que o
goleiro já não se interar mais amigo um
rumo um
agora vejo agora vejo muitos beijinhos
juntos vamos da mulher maria cheia de
graça estamos sempre né
eu não sei usar jesus nosso senhor está
conosco dá um sinal
não faço esse tipo de coisa sair mas a
marina silva não é porque gosta do banho
tomar vontade não não eu estava a filmar
enquanto fazia as coisas não não estava
pra ficar roxa e amigo estou aqui em
cima
olá vamos fazer comigo senão líbero é o
passador champs uol o boom 2010 pode ver
o quanto é que eu sou sua tela tão nova
e que às vezes eu acho que o objetivo é
passar pelos rins é é a pizza e no
brasil e isso e agora vão ser só
trabalhei na interseg estou aí né amigo
foi até mais do pai mas ela não tava
ouro um problema nem o que pensar para
promover a nossa inscrição e pra baixo
manhã ao aeroporto onde anda amigos que
têm tipo renda plantas à volta disto
pois exatos não joga
eu acho que aprendi lá embaixo não dar
todo meu amigo enfim quem meu
olha as coisas aqui é pra matar também
mané para matar tal beleza e farol
a série a ea carga a carga estava cheia
e quebrou o dedo do pé que vê nada
[Música]
[Aplausos]